thank you
[Music]
take a look at this picture and tell me
what you think that is what's Happening
Here a bunch of uh Barnacles oh I can't
see that a bunch of barnacles all right
what you got
oh no that looks like a [__] human
trying to be a sheep all right is that a
bag of that packaging popcorn is that a
person y'all talking about yeah like
packing peanuts the thing is that what
that is all right so what this is it's a
it's a um it's a prison break basically
this guy's escaping from jail trying to
look like a sheep that's so cool
yeah you make a good Warden was it like
a Mexican dude that's like ah fool it
actually
oh really
people did that they would just be like
this guy's a j cat which is a weirdo
like
okay
ours
[Laughter]
right and people talk to you in jail
about like trying to break out they're
probably like cuckoo a little bit yeah
they're cuckoo for Coco Puffs
I'm a
like most of the prisons are in the
middle of nowhere basically like
Ironwood is right on the border of like
in Blyth you guys want to reply it's
like right where Arizona is oh [__] if
I'm free you're gonna dice like within a
couple hours you know it's wow there's
no way hydrate it yeah for sure for sure
bro so there's no history like of like
there's no Legend of a guy like that how
that you're here I mean I think back in
the day right like maybe in like like
Alcatraz like there's all you know what
I mean but come on I bet all the
Alcatraz homies are like laughing at
those two like those [__] J cats like
those guys
two more years left
yeah but this dude was actually Bolivian
I believe he um he was serving 15 years
for homicide
and uh decided to create this uh looks
like a little skirt right here but he
created this like like wool cover this
camouflage or whatever camo yeah I don't
know how he got that far out that's
crazy he's crawling in the field to make
it look like he's a little sheep yeah he
just like started walking more instead
of just crawling do you think he would
have gotten caught if he what like if he
just was like walking or maybe if he
just ran yeah
get out of the out of the water he's
like he's like inching down rather than
just how about just run as fast as you
can
cheap indigenous to this area there's no
sheep out there nobody been important
sheeps for decades
this is [__] running on his two legs
I guess that's how he was um so he
wasn't even outside the wall yet he's
trying to sneak past the security that's
like Metal Gear Solid [__] bro yeah wait
there's [__] sheep in the prison
[Laughter]
yeah so he got as far as one of the
walls and then he was trying to break
through that wall as the ship
see him the whole time and they were
just like all right man look he's he's
getting out just let him do it and they
were like hey watch this
character and just like Ram it with his
head
[Laughter]
Johnny how many years have you done in
total like from childhood all the way
four plus eight and some [__] so like
you know almost 13. so it was four how
many in between your your adult eight
seven days I was out two months in holy
crap and then you went right back in
yeah
um go ahead bro
so you spend most of your childhood in
prison pretty much or like your youth
like my youth yeah yeah and then you got
out in your 20s yeah got out of my 20s
do you ever have when you got out
has there ever been moments where like
you've been tempted or like
to do things that you know will bring
you back in
like has there been any moments like
that absolutely yeah everyone go like
everyone goes through that bro like what
kept you to like not doing those things
honestly it was the pastor and the
religion yeah the not religion but
Christianity like it is a religion but
the pastor kind of was teaching me how
to think for the first time like back
then and I didn't think they're like you
guys want to rob people yeah let's do it
you guys want to do this yeah let's do
it it was just you just that was like
everyone was was like that you know and
I see that nowadays with with the youth
too if you notice like kids will speak
and just answer like what do you want to
eat food how was your day today good
like it affects a lot of people right
it's a sign that we don't think and
that's how how I was you know so
but yeah I would he taught me basically
like you have to kind of think deeply
because there's a difference between
deep thinking and overthinking right he
kind of pointed that out at the root of
deep thinking it's always empathetic
like you you have hope as you think
deeper like oh I did this you reflect
and you can do better make better
choices overthinking is always negative
like damn man why did I do yeah you're
so dumb man I shouldn't have done it and
it's just like it just snowballs yeah so
he was teaching me lacing me up like how
to think and how to think positive wow
yeah and I learned not to trust myself
whereas the whole world tells you follow
your heart trust yourself better than
yourself but like I was saying in the
interview my heart changes every day one
minute I'm happy next minute I'm like so
why would I trust something that's what
we call a flip-flop keeps changing if I
say one thing and do another thing it's
a lie right oh I'm gonna do this but I
do something else we don't trust people
like that but we trust ourselves and
that's why I was living this like up and
down lifestyle right just happy when I'm
happy but crash kick it with the homies
and then once I leave I'm all depressed
like it was just constantly like this
uphill you know that's something I
respected with what he said and he was
like oh if you're by default imperfect
yeah then you can't just trust yourself
right yeah exactly because if you do
then you're just gonna keep making
I was like I never heard that and I've
been to church for so long I don't give
a ton of them like oh I'm gonna trust my
God I'm like you guys stupid yeah you
said to say yeah that's the same thing
yeah oh trust your tracker yeah like
look at your track record has your gut
brought you in good places okay good
then maybe you have a good gut but most
people's good but you're not always
right and your gut's different all the
time come on like you know
your answers always change depending on
how you feel that's why they say like
when you're tired wait until you get
sweet to make the decision yeah yeah
that's right things
don't ever make it when you're mad yeah
yeah
because every time you'll just be like
I'm on a [__] divorce
it's like that's nothing to do with
with the racket is that Best Buy do you
want this sir
they're like sir would you like the big
screen or the flat screen I just want a
[__] divorce
that is true that's why that whole like
saying of sleeping on your decisions and
stuff yeah
yeah like even as like drinking water
you know what's crazy is like when I'm
irritated now right before I would just
act on it I'm just like [__] pissed
and then whatever I'm thinking about at
that moment is so real but then I'm like
hold on am I dehydrated drink some water
and I'm like oh I feel so much better
and then that those thoughts just
dissipate or like am I hungry right now
do I do do I need lunch like a baby that
hasn't had its nap and hasn't [__]
ate food and then now I'm like [__] dude
I wish I knew all of these basic things
about like
yo that's yeah I mean because we're not
we're still the same human as that
cranky baby that's [__] crying
because they they need rest that's still
you eating that time they need [__]
cuddles they need food yeah and all
those things if you get it you get your
rest it's like almost like when you were
thinking hella negative like oh man this
video is not even gonna do good I can't
pursue my dreams and [__] but when you
eat and then you're you're like you just
[__] had a workout you just feel a
million bucks you're just like man I
could take on the world dude that's
what's crazy to me is that the odds
with how um like we've been to church
most of our lives but our church sucked
bro and I've heard I've heard that same
thing in many different ways about like
oh do not do not give in to worldly
things or like what does that even mean
you've heard it right but the way that
that Pastor spoke to you like what are
the odds that that's the dude that you
got yeah well you could have gotten any
one of them not one of our [__]
[__] yeah you want to punch him in
the face probably yeah that's the same
old thing all right I heard it bro yeah
I got it yeah like the odds that you got
someone willing to take the time an
effort to learn how to speak to you and
especially at that time where you get
someone that could articulate those two
key points and those two two key
differences of overthinking versus deep
thinking like at that point it's already
deep thinking like man that's crazy you
could have got some dude who turned his
hat backwards when hey yo John check it
why you gotta do this though
you could have got that you spiritual
rap and you would have never went back
he's all like yo let me connect with the
youth
you got a Boombox
hey check out these Rhymes hey yo Johnny
you know why gangs aren't cool
do you want to hang out with God you
know I used to be from a gang myself it
was called the Key Club
[Laughter]
stupid
we used to do car washes living on the
edge oh my God you know what I said to
myself I need to live for God not for
secular purposes
I could relate
why'd you guys leave man why'd you leave
SDA dude that was so fun cool that's the
thing that the odds are that's what you
get yeah the odds are you get a lame ass
dude that's the odds
[Music]
laughs